[Music]
i was going to marry in tyler texas hey
mary what's going on
oh nothing much thank you for taking my
call you got it so what's going on how
can i help
okay so about two years ago i found out
that my husband was having an affair
with someone who lived in the same
neighborhood as us okay
and
whenever we found out he came clean that
we went to counseling
i found out because the woman's husband
found out and let me know
whoa how's that phone call
intense and it wasn't even a phone call
it was
the word cheetah written out in my front
yard
that's how i found out
and
he ended up the husband ended up calling
me that night telling me everything
because she admitted everything to him
well
um
recently
i have reason to think that they're
seeing each other again even though my
husband's claiming and that they're not
he's denying it every time i bring it up
and at this point i just don't know what
to do what makes you think he's doing it
again
um because i have him on an app where i
can see where he goes and
i've seen that he was at her house
so oh i'm laughing at
all of it
so you have him on like a digital leash
basically
exactly does he know this
yes
he's the one that admit that wanted to
do it because our counselor our marriage
counselor recommended it and he said
yeah i want to do it and he did it and
then so when you show him this app what
is he's like nah nah man no i was uh the
dog ate my phone and just ran over there
like what's he saying
he's saying that he was a glitch in the
app he don't trust the app
uh mary mary mary
he said other affairs hasn't he
yes this is the fourth affair that we
have since we've been married
my gosh
what are you doing
exactly why i'm calling you i don't know
you do
what is it about you that you don't
trust
there's a glitch in the app
what are you saying mary
and then every time it's like i feel
disconnected and he swears i'm gonna
change it i wasn't there i wasn't there
i'm not pleaser he's not
gonna change
he's not
he's not gonna change
and i don't know why you
have so little value in mary but i want
you to know i've only talked to you like
for three minutes and i like you
i think you're pretty fun
and i think you're probably really smart
and i think you've been living with a
gaslighter and an absolute pathological
liar someone who has absolutely no
regard for your happiness or your heart
or your marriage vows or anything
related to you
that's what i think
and i think you are worth way
way more
than following your husband around on
the phone like he's a video game and
then having him explain there's a glitch
in the matrix whatever dude
you know that's nuts so what do you do
next
exactly we have three kids together
but that was like i know listen you
didn't do this
you didn't do this
this happened to you
and you've boxed yourself into a corner
where if i respond to this
i blow this thing up
am i right
correct because a lot of times i see
stuff and i just keep it to myself i
know
and was just i was just talking to
myself before i took this call
you're not keeping it to yourself
because those three little ones are
absorbing every second of this
you have girls or boys
i had two boys and one girl you want
them to grow up with this model of what
a man looks like
no not at all do you want them to ever
do this to another woman what's being
done to you
never do you want your daughter to
understand that this is what love looks
like
no do you want a man to ever treat her
like you're being treated
no never
there's a period at the end of that
sentence
and you know this mary
do you have any sort of family support
any sort of friend or community of
support where you live
yes i have lots of family support okay
and i have a lot of family that's
telling me i need to just get out now
why aren't you
i'm so afraid for my kids
what are you afraid of
i don't want them to have to grow up in
two homes
they are in two homes inside the same
house it's making them crazy
they're already there
yeah you're right
it's already there
and it's so hard
yeah
so hard
and you've done everything you possibly
can for the last however many years
haven't you
yes
and he tells me every time he's gonna
change he's gonna make things better
he's gonna be more present
but it's hard to think how can you be
more present with us whenever you
have any second of thought about another
woman
it's it's deeper than that
it's deeper than that
i mean it's kind of about her but it's
not
you run you take care of everything you
take care of the food you take care of
home you take care of the kids
you just could do whatever he wants to
with whoever he wants to
none of the rules apply to him man
you're right says number four number
five you know i mean like nothing's ever
stuck
something about the future terrifies you
and i think it's because you don't think
you're worth it
i think you put that in my head
possibly
my guess is it's probably before that
maybe i'm wrong
somebody else put that in there
i think it's about the kids a little bit
just because it's the picture's
different right you don't want to be a
statistic you were going to be the one
are your parents divorced are they
together
together yeah so you've got a picture of
family
and you want that picture
and so you're grieving the fact that
that picture is going to be different
for you than you had set out to
and i get that
but i think it's deeper than that i
think you're terrified
of
asking yourself what i want
you feel like a sucker for keep coming
back and keep coming back and now you've
trapped yourself into a loop and i want
to tell you is you're worth more than
this you're worth being loved recklessly
somebody wakes up every day and just
thinks about you and they go to sleep
every night just thinking about you
and they wake up every day saying how
can i make mary's life incredible and
that frees you to think well how can i
make his life incredible
yeah
and somebody who's safe and somebody i
don't got to worry about every time i
sleep with my husband i might be
catching something from somebody
else and every time i go outside to get
in my car i'm worried about there being
another sign on my front yard from some
angry man
who my husband has gone into his home
it's just such an exhausting way to live
isn't it
it is
it's never you never have any peace no
and you know what you deserve
peace
you know what your kids deserve
when's the last time you fully exhaled
your shoulders are up right now i can
feel them
yeah you're right they are can you drop
them for me
take a deep breath and exhale
i just feel whenever i go through these
things
i just
get disconnected from myself from my
kids
you do because for some reason somebody
told you that what mary feels is not
real
but what mary feels and what mary wants
isn't worth listening to
what mary feels what mary thinks what
mary says is kind of dumb
to the point that you're even wondering
huh maybe there's a glitch in the app
of my serial cheater husband
like you thought that for a minute
yeah and then when somebody like me says
it back to you you hear how crazy that
sounds
it's true it does and then you feel
crazy for feeling crazy
and so hear me say you're not crazy mary
and you tried real real hard and i'm so
sorry
and i will never tell somebody except in
extreme abuse situations that they got
to get out of a marriage i'm not don't
you don't want you to hear me say that
but what i am telling you is you are
worth way more than the crap you're
dealing with now
and i think behavior is a language and
the language you have received over and
over is you are second or third or
fourth or fifth place you aren't worth
telling the truth you're not worth being
around to
you're not worth the thoughts you think
or the feelings you feel and neither are
my kids
yes
and
he does do this though whenever we
have these conversations he does like to
say
no but that's not really how you feel
this is how you feel
that's called gaslighting
when's the last time you talked to a
counselor
um
so i was going to a counselor for the
first affair right before i found out
about it because i was expecting
something but
i didn't know how to process it so i
started going to a counselor and i
didn't tell him and he was furious that
i was going and made me stop
so it was probably about two and a half
years ago
are you gonna stay are you gonna go
i think i need to go
you've been thinking that for a long
time are you gonna stay are you gonna go
i'm gonna go
when you say those words out loud and
your heart's broken and you weep
bitterly that doesn't mean it's the
wrong decision
that means your body may exhale for the
first time and release all that stuff
that's been holding for a long long time
and if you choose to stay i'll be here
okay
okay your family still loves you
but he's not gonna change
there's no reason to change he has no
reason to change at all ever
he goes
he's got a freedom
that's what people are saying and the
thought of saying just feels heavy
of course it does
because your body's under attack it's at
war
it's exhausting
it's tired of wondering am i going to
catch a disease am i going to get my are
you going to find you dead in the front
porch
are my kids going to turn into this
right
that
the
when our feelings and our thoughts are
just compressed and compressed and
compressed and shoved and shoved and
shoved into a tiny little pocket in the
back of our soul
the hand motion there is just it
compressing another word for compress it
just depresses everything
and you've been in fight or flight or
freeze for so long you don't even know
what it's like to breathe
to laugh from your guts
you don't know what it's like to guy
walk in have your heart flutter again
because every time a guy walks into your
house your heart sinks
yeah
every time you get a text message you
don't think
you think
and i'm tired of seeing him get text
messages and wondering who they are of
course
absolutely
when's the last time you said that
sentence out loud
i don't even know exactly
you got a lot of things left unsaid over
the last few years mary and you need to
sit down with somebody and start saying
them out loud whether that's your friend
whether that's your family whether
that's a counselor
whether that's a lawyer
but the i need you to hear me say
you are worth more than this those two
little kids are worth more than this
the decision is yours sister and we're
going to be with you every step of the
way
i'm going to holler back at me and let
me know what you decide to do and how
that goes
and if you decide to go i want you to
make sure you've got people rallied
around you're going to be surprised
people show up with a moving van to this
one
my guess is you got friends and family
that are waiting waiting waiting waiting
waiting for you to make that call
they will be over there and clear that
house out in 30 minutes
or they will take all his stuff and
set it in the neighbor's yard
evidently he really really wants to be
thank you so much for the call mary for
your bravery
time for you to make a decision hun
i won't be with you every step of the
way